hi I'm Erik Bosse and that Avengers end
game trailer was really playing its
cards close to the chest revealing that
all the Avengers are super bummed out a
possible clue about time travel and some
mysterious mission that's Steve a
Natasha are going on this is good work
Steve I know it is cuz I don't know what
I'm gonna do if it doesn't mmm that's
not how plans work Steve like I get it
high hopes power positive thinking the
secret but people without fallback plan
still fail all the time but we don't
know what his plan is I've been rambling
on about this and a number of videos but
some interesting clues have emerged that
could give us some insight on what cap
and Natasha are doing and when they're
doing it and why they're gomorrah inna
okay can we just retire that joke please
Thanks well we're warning in case I
accidentally get anything right and
ruining life okay one important detail
to note in this clip from the in-game
trailer is this compass this is the one
given to Steve by Peggy Carter remember
in the first Captain America the First
Avenger movie he put it on the dashboard
of the Valkyrie as he took down the
plate into the Arctic ice it was the
closest Steve Rogers got to getting that
date with Peggy and let's be honest it's
closer than most of us have ever gotten
on dates with anyone YouTube is our
girlfriend so I imagine it's pretty
important that cap and net have this
compass this compass was a symbol of
caps unwavering morality the needle
always stubbornly points north just like
Steve always stubbornly does the right
thing
now in my breakdown of the end game
trailer I pointed out how according to
that compass cap and net are facing
north east and at the time I saw an
interesting coincidence with the other
big recent Marvel trailer the one for
Captain Marvel which featured a brief
shot of Carol Danvers and Nick Fury and
an old Quinn jet in which the heading
was listed as twenty point six degrees
which is north northeast connected
that's hard to say the scene with
Danvers and Fury was set in the 90s and
it's probably just part of a different
story than whatever cabin a door up to
but then what really crazy coincidence
came up brought to our attention by
Jaden on Twitter that the heading speed
and altitude of the Quinjet the danvers
inferior are sitting in in the Captain
Marvel trailer are the exact same
heading speed and altitude of the Quinn
jet that cap and Agent Coulson took in
the first Avengers movie as they headed
towards the Helicarrier this is pretty
nuts like sure 530 miles per hour and
over 30,000 feet are pretty standard
speeds and altitudes for any commercial
jetliner but for both of them to be
traveling the exact same heading of 20
point six degrees that's weird
like why are several of shield's
quinjets and different decades heading
the precise north northeastern vector
down to the tenth of a degree is this
just that designers reusing old sets new
way here's my attempt to tie all these
weird connections together okay we know
Captain America crashed the Valkyrie
into the Arctic ice according to his
radar screen during that scene the
landmasses looks similar to the islands
of northeastern Canada along the Arctic
Circle perhaps the waterways between
Ellis Moore Island and Greenland
somewhere in that vicinity that location
is located north northeast from the
southwestern United States where we
believe Carol Danvers and Nick Fury are
in that scene in the trailer as well as
north-northeast from New York where
Captain America is probably located at
the start of the Avengers ian remember
right before cap crashed the Valkyrie
the tesseract which of course contains a
space stone burned a hole through the
vessel and fell into the icy water below
sometime after that Howard Stark
recovered it and then shield launched
project Pegasus to experiment with it so
maybe this is all about that moment cap
lost the tesseract in the Arctic sea
like let's imagine a scenario in which
the tesseract which remember is a
temperamental object that creates
wormholes through space could have torn
a rift in space on the ocean floor where
it landed it could have done this before
Howard Stark recovered it after World
War 2 and then that brick has just been
sitting there releasing all kinds of
cosmic crap into the Arctic sea stuff
that Shield has had to secretly deal
with maybe years later shield director
Nick Fury might want to establish a
secret shield base nearby and he would
need a very powerful force to help
maintain that cosmic balance it'd be
handy to have a very powerful hero in
place to guard that portal like the way
Heimdall guards the entrance to as guard
in this case Earth's Heimdall could be
Captain Marvel that would explain why
Nick Fury wouldn't have called Captain
Marvel to help the Avengers in the
Battle of New York she couldn't help
plug the wormhole over stark tower
because she would need to maintain her
pose to make sure that wormhole at the
bottom the ocean stay plugged maybe Fury
would have been checking on her right
before cap and Coulson arrived
the Avengers and I could explain that
quinjets north northeastern heading and
back in the 90s that could be where fury
and Danvers were initially headed in
that Quinn jet explaining that same
north northeastern heading so what are
captain Natasha doing in this clip and
the endgame trailer
well another endgame related videos I
made recently I'd pose the possibility
that the movie could explore time travel
with the Avengers hopping back in time
to specific moments to destroy the
Infinity stones one by one before they
could fall in the wrong hands during the
wrong gauntlets what is cap and Nats
mission is to recover the space stone
prevent the tesseract from falling out
of the valkyrie look again at that clip
in the end game trailer it's kinda hard
to tell but I'm not so sure cap and that
are in the avengers quintet they're like
the quinn jet has bright big windows
from the cockpit that light up the back
part of the vessel and that back part's
pretty cramped i could be wrong but this
vessel just looks darker more open
honestly kind of like the interior of
the valkyrie or some other metal ship
maybe cap and that are on the valkyrie
back in the year 1943 that could explain
why Peggy's photo and that compass
hasn't really faded and wilted maybe
their goal could be to procure the
tesseract in that moment and to destroy
the space stone so that shield can't
meddle with the tesseract and awaken it
attracting Thanos his first assault led
by Loki and then hopefully preventing
Thanos from ever acquiring the space
stone and then dealing a major blow to
his whole conquest I mean I don't know
when I watch this in-game trailer clip
Kappa Natasha just sounds so
experimental with their tone they don't
sound like warriors facing a mission
that will test their combat skills or
stealth they kind of sound like crackpot
scientists testing a theory to see if
their hypothesis works out the way that
they hope it will incap not knowing what
I'll do if it doesn't work suggests that
this dude seems bewildered by time and
destiny like if their mission to alter a
timeline fails it would mean Diana's
victory is fated and Kappas not in
control of his destiny and at that point
yeah he truly wouldn't know what to do
with himself comment down below with
your thoughts on this theory and foe
under rock stars on Twitter at me rock
stars follow me on Twitter and Instagram
at a boss you could be more part of our
team by supporting us on patreon and
thank you so much to all of our current
patrons especially Kenny Smith and
subscribe to new rock stars for more
Avengers endgame theories like my theory
about how the ghost of Peggy Carter will
haunt Steve Rogers and Peggy's great
nice Aaron Carter whenever Steven Sharon
tried to hook up you know she's like 70
years younger than you you create make
it happen Mikey
[Music]